il devrait être une soixantaine mais ne
sont qu'une dizaine dans cet
amphithéâtre tous inscrits en pharmacie
les autres travaillent à domicile car la
paces c'est aussi beaucoup de travail
individuel le numerus clausus en
pharmacie ces cinq places aux antilles
c'est quand même assez décourageant novo
qui attribue deux places où un homme
conséquent d'élèves mais hansson km
motivé pour prendre tous les coups sous
les ponts et ses défauts de montrer ça
nous donne une habitude de travail plus
que ces codes ceci de la rigueur
sanctionné par la dure loi du numerus
clausus entre 2016 et 2019 3145 inscrits
soit 1000 étudiants parents en paces et
seulement 200 places proposées chaque
année dont 130 en médecine autant dire
qu'il faut viser à tout prix le haut du
tableau
certains échouent pour quelques
centièmes de points c'est le cas de
kenji triplant en médecine avec une
moyenne de 13 75 on a vu les erreurs du
numerus clausus
mais je pense néanmoins que cette
nouvelle formule va donner d'autres
possibilités qui seront tout à fait
abordable et qui vont va dire ouvrir le
champ des possibilités toutes sortes
détient 60 des reçus mais qui sont en
même temps
allez donc ce qui veut dire que c'est
pas bon ça c'est c'est pas bon jeu 13 de
moyenne un étudiant est il et il est bon
d'accord très très moyen ça donne une
mention assez bien
alors est-ce que désormais tout le monde
pourra accéder à cette deuxième année
quelle que soit sa note
non la sélection se fera plus tard mais
déjà l'étau se desserre les réfractaires
eux dénoncent une formation médecine ou
rabais alors que d'autres on sait qu'il
ya des gens qui réussissent le concours
et qui ne seront pas de bons médecins et
des gens quittent échoue à ce concours
et qui aurait pu être de très très bons
médecins
donc la question n'est pas vraiment là
je pense que si on multiplie par 1,5 ou
2 le nombre de personnes reçues
ça ne va absolument pas diminuer le
niveau global des médecins d'ici à 2030
le ministère de la santé espère 20 % de
médecins supplémentaires à condition
qu'ils profitent au pays
le retour après le second cycle a été
proposé cette semaine par jean-philippe
ni leur proposition rejetée par
l'assemblée nationale